welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka YouTube's
number two and Picard is back with its
fifth episode our mission is to boldly
go where no one has gone before and give
our thoughts on the new entry as well as
what could be happening in the future
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the
fitnah pursuits plot it's Easter eggs
and what we thought of it as a whole we
will be engaging with heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
catch the show yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of Picard
episode 5 ok so just a quick recap of
the series so far after the death of
data's daughter Dodge
Picard made it his mission to track down
a twin sister so Chih Picard put
together a crew and set out into the
stars to find her along the way he
picked up a young Romulan from his past
named Elinor and also bumped into seven
of nine
episode 5 picks up on the planet
vergessen of the seven domes and this is
a flashback set thirteen years ago this
continues the Stech that we've had so
far in the season and it looks like all
of our episodes are going to open in the
past to showcase how things happen the
way that they did the Star Trek Voyager
episode imperfection ties in heavily
with this entry so if you want some
required reading that's probably what
you need to check out it's not
completely compulsive but it does set up
a lot of things here we see a grueling
operation in which is synthetic eyes
removed from each AB who you may
remember from Star Trek Voyager the
actor is different so I didn't initially
pick up on this but it is indeed the
same character each ever was a former
Borg drone that was discovered by the
Voyager and he eventually joined the
crew and became a close friend of seven
of nine due to their commonality we
learn in the episode that the Gangstar
vajazzle no.not vajazzle has been
butchering xborgs for parts and this is
why she has the character captive here
seven of nine shows up to save the day
but it's too late and each herb asks for
death due to his wounds and the
experimentation 7m9 begrudgingly carries
this out and it's a big death for the
season
we be interested to hear reactions to I
don't want to make too many assumptions
here as to what's going on but it's
clear that the Borg are once more being
painted out as the victims rather than
the bad guys that they used to be this
adds further way to the theory that
they're being persecuted and I'll get
into this later in the breakdown from
here we jump to start a city and free
cloud two weeks prior to the events of
the show we discover that Bruce Maddox
has gotten deep with the gangsters most
namely by Jaisal Maddox has been one of
the main MacGuffins of the show so far
along with Sochi and it's good to
finally see the character in an episode
we learned that the Tal Shiar after him
and this is likely because of his work
on dodging Sochi it's been long said
that Maddux is the cyberneticist that
created the two because he was wishing
to make an Android that was as complex
as data he may have achieved this in the
twins and thus he is a key component in
finding them we also know that their
mother was fake and it's very likely
that they have different simulations
that have raced them through Maddux's
programming he reveals in the episode
that he knows where they are and this
pretty much confirms that it was him
that sent the characters to their
respective locations dodges mother did
tell her to go find Picard so it's
likely that he's been a guardian angel
for them in the episode we learned that
Agnes and Maddux had a relationship and
this is why she joined the quest I do
think that she is a mole because I went
to see her and know we'll find out there
are a lot of clues in this episode now
similar to each ebb the original actor
did not return for Maddux and it is a
shame that they didn't manage to get the
two back Maddox is drugged by the Jaisal
and she plans to sell him to the Tal
Shiar and this becomes the thrust of the
episodes plot Picard in seven of nine
have a sit down and we learned that the
latter is pretty much a vigilante that
works for a group known as the Rangers
the Rangers have been going through the
galaxy and righting wrongs and this
makes her want to align herself with
Picard she joins the mission as a
trusted ally and helps them a lot in
this entry seven of nine spent two
decades living on earth and this is why
his speech pattern has changed quite a
lot Jeri Ryan who plays the character
said that this was a conscious choice to
show how much she has changed in order
to get to the jazel and this Maddux
seven of nine offers herself up knowing
that her Borg parts will be irresistible
to the character this will hopefully
swagger jazel away from dealing with the
Tal Shiar and instead she will hopefully
sell to them
the infiltrates TARDIS city and the Las
Vegas esque location requires some fancy
dress and some new identities it's a
hilarious aesthetic in the episode and
by far the biggest departure for the
show thus far it's a lot of fun and no I
was worried this scene would be like the
Kanto bites bit from Star Wars the last
Jedi they have their tongue place firmly
in their cheek so it works a lot better
in my opinion the group have to pretend
to be the bad guys and it's funny seeing
the over-the-top gangster getup
eyepatch in all Tommy as hell and I
loved seeing that Elmo basically has the
personality of a buckingham palace guard
it's more in line with episodes of the
next generation and it's nice to see
this style in the show Rafi has her own
mission and goes looking for a man named
Gabriel Huang this takes her to start a
city reproductive health services which
turns out to be a family planning clinic
here we learn that Gabriel is in fact a
CERN and the two have in a strange
relationship because Rafi went off the
deep end after a career was ruined in
the wake of Picard's resignation
Rafi became a conspiracy theorist and
due to her believed that the attack on
Mars was an inside job this drove a
wedge between them
Starfleet knocked down the towers this
further adds way to the theory at the
moment that the Romulans were behind the
synth uprising and that they carried
this out in order to make the galaxy
hate since as much as they did
due to the supernova striking their
planet they had the perfect alibi and
the government could have viewed this as
a necessary sacrifice in order to get
their way we do know that a lot of
Romulans survived and it could be
possible that these were specifically
chosen by the leaders of the planet in
order to weed out the weak either way
this thinking that something else is
going on has massively damaged Rafi's
relationship with a family Gabriel's
wife is a Romulan and we can assume from
this that a constant digging at
something may have caused problems
especially if she believes that the
Romulans had something to do with it the
Romulans knocked down the towers
anyway I'm jumping the gun a bit but it
paints how deep that the repercussions
of Picard's actions are and it's kind of
heartbreaking to see that she won't
really be in a grand child's life back
in the hive of scum and villainy
vajazzle and seven
nine come face-to-face once more we get
a lot more of seven of nines backstory
filled in and it turns out that they
have a history but she managed to get
away and she's had a vendetta ever since
we also learn at seven of nines name is
anneka and that she has her own things
going on it's revealed that getting to
me Jaisal has been sevens plan the
entire time and that she's played Picard
it just as much as they were playing the
gangster turns out that after the rescue
attempts decades prior that the universe
destabilized and seven of nine would
defend wrists to try and keep the peace
it was an ambush and each ebb was taken
by the Jaisal during this and stripped
of the pots that we saw in the
introduction but Jaisal offers a trade
up of a life form Alex and the group but
grudgingly agrees with Maddux they
travel back to the ship and seven of
nine decides to part ways
she takes guns from Picard but she
offers up the services for the future
which I think the character will
definitely be picking up on when he's
been painted into a corner seven of nine
is of course part Borg so it does make
sense with the fact that they are going
to the Borg cube in the future their
parting is a really somber moment and
Picard says that after leaving the
collective he did lose some of his
humanity but it is possible to get it
back and that they have to work on it
seven of nine clearly doesn't have his
yet but you'll try to regain it every
damn day of a life also we think she
returns immediately to vajazzle duel
wielding the guns that she's just taken
and says that she didn't want to destroy
Picard's hope and thus pretended that
there would be some good in her
potentially she kills vajazzle and goes
out guns blazing and personally it's my
favorite moment in the season so far
I really think it works well and I love
going from the emotional moment of the
exchange between Picard and seven to
pretty much this all-out brawl Picard
breaks the news to Maddox that daash is
dead but he confirms that she does have
a sister and that she's on the board
cube agnes looks suspicious as hell at
this point and again this does make me
believe she's a mole that's relaying
information back to Starfleet Maddox
reveals that he sent shoji to the cube
to find the truth about the conspiracy
that's going on between the Romulans and
the Federation I do you believe that the
Federation are tied in with the Romulans
and we do know from Admiral can see that
several systems were planning and
leaving until the
darica pricing and it is possible at the
to win it together we also learn the
Agnes was part of Sochi in Dodgers
programming and that she helped in
creating them she murders Maddux
potentially to cover up her involvement
and though she seems heartbroken it's
clear that someone is pulling the
strings with her I do believe that
Starfleet is behind this and that they
sent Agnes to find out what Sochi knows
as well as where the nests could be
there has been lip service paid to the
nest which is where Maddux could have
hidden the rest of this index I'm not
100% on that theory so yet drop your
thoughts if you pick something else up
as I'm sure many people will have
differing opinions as for next week it
looks like Picard and Co are finally
going to the Borg cube to try and rescue
Sochi we see that she's close to
discovering who she really is and
personally I believe it will be revealed
that she is the Borg Queen and this is
why the Romulans have been keeping such
a close eye on her the fact that she can
activate and easily kill people shows
that she has some untapped power and
someone known as the destroyer is likely
a high-ranking member of the androids we
see that Picard is having flashbacks to
being a Borg himself and they'll have
seen some people say that he may be
assimilated next week if Yuri watch the
promo it's definitely shown it's a
flashback this will probably be the way
that they open the episode next week as
yeah you know you know they love a good
flashback overall there's a lot to look
forward to and I can't wait to see what
happens next week this is my favorite
episode so far and I'm glad that the
show is just constantly improving
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Picard so comment below and let me
know if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up make sure you
check out our full breakdown of the
series so far which is gonna be linked
at the end you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it it
goes a long way to helping videos like
this get made you wanna come chat us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey will click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see you
over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]